The Launchpad is a five
day boot camp for startups.
Everything from the design
all the way through to user
experience all the way through
to the pitching process.
I have learnt absolutely
everything I wanted to know.
'Cause we have gotten
business advice, and sales,
and modeling advice.
Everything was practical.
It was like a bit
business-oriented.
My business has definitely
taken some different directions
because of Launchpad.
Our mentor session
on Monday really
pushed us to make a
product from an idea.
We practically saved.
I think approximately
two months, maybe three,
of our development time,
and countless hours
of the user research, market
research, everything, probably
our company, to be honest.
Yes.
A lot of the mistakes
you make as a startup,
we hopefully are not
going to make them.
Or we made them in
such a short time
that we still have enough
time and budget to continue.
Google Launchpad saved us.
Yes.
Bye!